you know uh nate nothing says open for
business like a 55-foot praying mantis
breathing fire
at container park yeah in fact uh
that so-called sculpture is going to be
roaring back to life
after a hibernation our bianca holman is
downtown right now where
hey business looks like it's picking up
again bianca
oh yeah it definitely is naden so this
praying mantis it went dormant
last year that was march 18th when it
went dormant
but as downtown container park
celebrates the return
of this praying mantis it'll be
breathing fire again as more shoppers
and more nightlife comes to this area
now there are more positive signs that
are happening downtown that life is
returning a little
over a mile away from container park the
first friday festival returns
in person tomorrow night in the arts
district the monthly party it's been
online on the web
since april of 2020 some downtown
business owners tell us they're seeing
pre-pandemic levels of foot traffic at
local restaurants and shops
it is so great i mean you know the fact
that you know the city has just
continued to support us you know even
through the pandemic
and they're still coming here and
they're still you know staying true to
us i mean it's it's really awesome to
see
some credit vaccinations and pent up
energy for the business boost
the city of las vegas is also helping
out by putting up banners in key
districts near downtown like
restaurant row on carson avenue and
unfortunately first friday
is already booked up but the praying
mantis it will be breathing fire
starting tonight at seven o'clock
and of course at dusk on friday and
saturday evenings
reporting live from downtown las vegas
bianca holman 8 news now